الامير هاري يقف في منصه الشهود لمقاضاه
المجموعه المالكه لصحيفه ذمرر البريطانيه
التي يتهمها بالتنصت على هاتفه وانتهاك
خصوصيته بصوره غير قانونيه ولكن ما هي
ابرز ادعاءات هذه حول قضيه انتهاك الصحافه
لخصوصياتهم هي 33 نموذجا من القصص الخبريه
المنشوره في مجموعه زمرد من اصل طبعا 147
قصه التطفل غير القانوني على خصوصيه هذه
وصل الى ملاعب مدرسه ايتن وهناك قصتان
تناقشان تناقشان طبعا الاصابات الرياضيه
للامير بعدما نشرت صحيفه ديلي ميرو عام
2000 ان الامير هاري اجرى عمليه جراحيه
بسيطه في ذراعه بعد اصابه مرتبطه بالكره
القدم
والتي توضح بالتفصيل نصائح محدده قيل ان
الاطباء قدموها للصبي البالغ من العمر 16
عاما طبعا بعد 11 شهرا ذكرت صحيفه
في تقرير بعنوان
بان الاطباء امروا الامير بالتوقف عن لعب
عن اللعب بسبب اصابه في الظهر طبعا بحسب
هذه الصحيفه ايضا بعض من القصص الثلاث 33
تغطي شؤون الاسره الداخليه احدها نشرتها
مجله في ديسمبر من العام 2003 تعرض ايضا
تفاصيل الخلاف بين الامير والامير ويليام
حول سلوك رئيس فريق خدم والدتهما السابق
المحكمه ستتطرق ايضا الى القصص المعروفه
عن الامير الشاب مثل شرب الكحول وتعاطي
المخدرات وغير هذه القصص بعدما ذكرت احدى
قصص ساندي ميرير عام 2002 بان الامير
تشارلز انذاك اعطها لتحذيرا صارما متعلقا
بتدخين الحشيش
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات